bertrand c'est votre anniversaire
aujourd'hui père comme eh bien oui et
oui alors sachez qu'on a un très très
beau cadeau pour vous jure que c'est
vrai bertrand mokhtar est ce que vous
pouvez amener bertrand voir tout de
suite son cadeau allez vous puisque
bertrand va voir son cadeau merci
bertrand qui va y aller oui c'est
l'anniversaire de bertrand il fête ses
26 ans aujourd'hui bertrand donc
forcément on s'est dit qu'on allait lui
faire un beau petit cadeau est-ce que
bertrand est hors champ est ce qu'on
peut continuer démission ce qu'on dira
oui c'est bon parce que regarder est ce
que vous vous rappelez de ces de cette
vidéo qu'on vous avait montré cette
vidéo japonaise on s'est dit que ça
pourrait faire un beau cadeau pour
berlin à regarder celle où tôt
squido
non
bon
voir
est ce qu'il est prêt
alors on s'est dit que c'était un beau
cadeau qu'on bertrand bertrand ce qui
nous attend bertrand mercredi qu on peut
le voir est ce qu on al mawlid de
bertrand tle savamment bertrand c'est
bon maintenant on pouvait le laisser
respirer ces votes à rester alors
bertrand et bien oui autres cadeaux vous
le savez qu'on vous aime beaucoup mon
bertrand louis bertrand où on pouvait
pas vous laisser comme ça bertrand voilà
c'est votre cadeau non ne vous inquiétez
pas il va paraître c'est quelque chose
qui va se faire très plaisir
c'est le parti qui était pas mais
retenant la mais sérieux c'est rien je
ne m'inquiétais pas c'est que c'est que
des votes y aller
voilà
anniversaire omeyer et bertrand sanaa
bordelais qu il fera sa chronique à tout
à l'heure il va revenir il joue même
comme ça ça veut dire même comme ça il
est debout
bertrand super merci
la thérapie vous allez vous en souvenir
ah bah ouais mais c'est sympa salut mon
père trop